you kind of really have blinders on it
and don't let yourself become
comfortable let's play it safe you can't
take on a job because oh well what am i
good news I've got to be a good one
you have to just always go by your gut
she's an American actress producer and
businesswoman she gained worldwide fame
for playing Rachel Green on a TV sitcom
friend she's one of the highest-paid
actresses in Hollywood she's Jennifer
Aniston and here's my take on her top
ten rules for success
rule number two is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around although
to the end for some special bonus clips
also as Jennifer is talking if you test
out then it really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so that other
people can be inspired and also when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick in your head to enjoy
[Music]
I think I was getting stuck myself
feeling nervous to take a chance and you
know forgetting the fact that I'm an
actor and I can play different parts and
I've been on ice to do character shows
or sketch comedy shows where I would do
hundreds of characters and all of a
sudden you get very safe and very you
can feel stuck and not only do you feel
stuck that the the world sort of sticks
you somewhere they put you in a little
box and in a category and and so that's
what I learned from it was don't listen
you kind of really have blinders on it
and don't let yourself become
comfortable and play it safe because
you'll burn out and I want to do this
for a while I want to be around for a
little while longer when the trip comes
to you when somebody's sending you a
script I mean what are you looking
character first you're looking story
first you're looking for the whole
project and now the whole kit and
caboodle I'd say the character the story
and am I going to have a really good
time and my can I connect to it doesn't
have to be real serious or this or that
can be a big blockbuster hit comedy and
it just want it to be really fun and
enjoyable the outcomes always going to
be the out you never know what the
outcomes going to be you can't do it for
you can't take on a job because oh well
what am I good this has got to be a good
one you have to just always go by your
gut and if you're going to enjoy
yourself and have a good time creatively
and work with people timesaver don't
work as an angry people don't work with
pain-in-the-ass factors don't work with
you know get all your information and
say yeah life's too short
rule that falls under that I will move
on anyone I hopefully that you called
things into your life and that things
happen as they should when when you're
ready for it that's what happened the
other day I was doing yoga and with my
girlfriend and we were we finished we
were sort of sitting there just sort of
stretch in and I looked over at her and
I said you know what I have to say I'm
feeling a feeling I have I don't know if
I've ever actually felt before and that
is that
I don't want to be anywhere other than
where I am right now sitting across okay
I'm not I'm not sitting somewhere
dwelling on the past or I'm not
spreading or you know obsessing about
something in the future or something
that was you know it's just it was a
feeling of total peace and I love that
how did you how did you get there
because you had to have you had to shed
some tears you had to have some all's
way more like oh my god me neither -
yeah yeah so you know although I did not
burst into tears at the opening of that
article by the way I'll just say that
but anyway so you shed some tears it
some tears but meaning you know it was
it's sort of that the the living in the
moment and the in the now as they say in
all the self-help books because if I had
a dollar for every book that was sent my
way yeah I could have probably paid for
this studio but you know I really needed
two dollars two dollars
[Applause]
dollars per family yes so but yeah you
can read the bill and read them and you
can sort of intellectualize it but the
truth is and you sit there going oh how
do I do that you know and you're
frustrated and then you get down on
yourself because you're not there yet
and then you just realize one day it's
just happened it's collected in your you
know your your your cellular memory and
and that's and then one day you're
sitting there with your friend doing
yoga and you go oh I get it
I'm ok I get it you know we all have
varying degrees of loss and sadness and
pain in our lives and it's it's a
necessity honestly because then how
would we appreciate the good times and
the hopeful times and all of the the
abundance that life has if you know if
you go and grab it but it's just your
bits of personal choice to to get up and
move on and be better I was saying the
other day to somebody you know I I think
all actors who are you know maybe
gratefully may or successful sometimes
if you're if you're you know identified
with something like friends or if you
almost feel like you're an actor in a
closet always trying to like like I I
want to do more you know what I mean and
and it's always there's always a little
bit of a struggle and a challenge but I
find that exciting you know what I mean
and to keep to keep pushing myself and
to keep challenging myself and taking
risk I think it's important not to get
lazy and stay safe you have to
understand when you have nothing to
compare it to you and you just get to go
to work and you see so many of your
friends who are not working I'm just
grateful to be working and doing movies
that I found fun and entertaining and
some were loved and some were not and
you know and then it wasn't until I got
really a lot started getting older where
I realized I think having done some a
good girl it made me really sort of
realize I have a choice of what I can do
you know I really can explore other
things and and not just sit back and
just wait for what handed to
you you know so I think I started back
then making movement being more
conscious and vocal with my managers and
agents about stuff you know areas that I
wanted to explore and now you've been
into yoga for years and you also
meditate yeah so what are some of the
biggest changes that that have brought
to your life you know I sure it's kind
of not one thing you can point at or put
a finger on it's just it's just there's
I just can tell you that I feel it just
it's like a kickstart for your day it
just centers you and things your stress
levels are just down and you find
yourself interacting in the world much
easier and better and in a calmer way
and there's just a peaceful joy that
sort of comes over and you can't I don't
know how or why it's no rhyme or reason
and I just know that if I if I go
through a phase where I flip off and I'm
not religious with it I feel the
difference yeah feel it well and for
people that are maybe a little bit
intimidated about taking up meditation
what can you tell them just you don't
have there's nothing to do wrong you
can't do it wrong so there's you could
go and take a class if you want you can
have someone come you know give you
training in it or you can just find
something that works for you you can
just listen to beautiful music and just
find gratitude and whatever is here or
in what and you're in in what you have
all I can say is you can't do it if you
can't mess it up I have you ever again
no names no name have you ever accepted
a project and then been into it a couple
of weeks and said not to the world and
not to me but to your best friend hmm I
don't think this is what I expected it
to be yes I have
alright so now no names our deal
but I think I'm going to actually name a
name
it was just not happen but how do you
get through that then I mean that play
you get fairly vigorously weeks into it
and then you've got another three or
four or six weeks of shooting you make
the best of it you do the view and just
take care of your job you know and your
talk and as they have as much of a
dialogue with them as you possibly can
and you know just get in there get get
very involved sometimes you can just sit
back and just do your job and sometimes
it's important that you kind of be a bit
more collaborative you know I was always
a yo-yo Dyer I was a you know a chubbier
kid did you do drastic things to dial I
was it was I like bulimic or anorexic
person no but I was a diet aholic
definitely grapefruit diet remember
there's the watermelon diet there was
the white grain of rice diet different
she works out three to four days a week
and has learned to make eating about
life now not a reaction to the past
a father who broke up the family and two
volatile mother one say to all these
young girls there are so many struggles
that everybody has specially when it's
like you don't know what you're filling
up are you filling up a void is it your
father leaving is it is it your fear of
failure is it that I will never be that
thin I will never be as beautiful as you
whoever you are and I think once you
become once you figure out your you know
who you are and who what you love about
yourself I think it all kind of falls
into place
eventually alright so here's that we
played take turns acting out clues to
the other person and they have to get
the word in the monitor so there's going
to be a word behind me I can't see it
reach have one minute to get the other
person to guess as many as we can and
you're the guess I will let you go first
okay and so okay here and I'll have to
guess as many in one minute as I can
okay okay game is chilling up game is
queuing up get ready oh it's like okay
jump rope hello
[Applause]
parking you're a monkey are you're
impaired but you're running man running
[Applause]
cheering here later oh oh gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because or soul you
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the couch below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what a Jennifer
stays that has the biggest impact on you
what lesson are you going to take from
this and immediately apply it to your
life of your business leave it down in
the comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also wanna give a quick
shout out to em D McGill thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
here one word and taking that awesome
picture on what looks like an amazing
sunny beautiful day I hope you enjoy the
read and thank you for sharing thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved Jesus
what would you say to your 20 year old
self though oh my 20 year old self hi we
were quite away yeah I would say and
enjoy it oh yeah that's good that's why
I really enjoy it enjoy it yeah this is
this yeah really don't fret so much nope
reading this is a really wonderful thing
that we get to do to make people laugh
and entertain people and it's it's it's
it's where if we're lucky so enjoy that
and listen to people when they when they
tell you how how much joy you bring to
their living rooms or their movies pay
attention